les turbulences lieu de conservation
d'exposition du frac centre val de loire
possède la seule collection existante
sur l'architecturé expérimental ici
c'est l'exposition temporaire
visionnaire qui explorent de nouveaux
modèles mettant en scène une vingtaine
de projets urbains de grande échelle
pour la plupart en cours de réalisation
une question président aux collections
ou vivrons-nous de demain cette
interrogation le frac propose d'y
réfléchir avec les scolaires au travers
d'actions pédagogiques
alors quelle est la différence entre une
architecture normale et
d'expérimentation monsieur
l'expérimentation on essaie des choses
gilles en charge des publics au frac
rencontre une classe du collège de
bazoges légal rend le dialogue se fait
autour du thème la ville du futur
on a créé cette année un dispositif qui
s'appelle ville du futur est une
exposition itinérante qui se promène de
d'établissement en établissement sur
l'ensemble de la région centre ils sont
6 cette année à accueillir un dispositif
qui à la fois fait de 10 fac similé puis
d'une maquette à chaque fois c'est pas
une visite
c'est vraiment une rencontre parce que
l'idée c'est de discuter avec les élèves
des pièces qu'ils voient autour d'eux
par exemple la m'inquiète donc guèye
seck est à côté de moi j'aurais très
bien pu dérouler un nom notice apprise
par coeur et ça n'a aucun intérêt
alors pourquoi ces modernes en élève
convient le rencontrer on vient pas
rencontré uniquement une personne en
phase d'apprentissage
on va rencontrer citoyens on va
rencontrer quelqu'un qui est capable de
porter un regard
je crois que vous travaillez notamment
sur l'idée du nid d'abeille l'intérêt
c'est de montrer que ce n'est pas
l'architecte tout seul qui va faire le
paysage humain c'est aussi et surtout
d'abord les habitants le citoyen le
dialogue autour de l'exposition vient
nourrir un travail en arts plastiques et
l'art nécessite souvent du bricolage
mais ne vous y trompez pas clous vis
grillage marteau et s'ils sont en
service d'un concept
de la ruche à la ville comment créer la
cité du futur est ce que vous avez pensé
que peut-être d'un côté les loisirs d'un
côté des affaires pourquoi
l'environnement est ce qui est
intéressant pédagogiquement ya plusieurs
aspects vous pouvez dire le plus
lointain dans le derme et parce qu'elle
est très proche de nous c'est la
citoyenneté c'est comment penser
l'habitat la manière de vivre la manière
dont va vivre ensemble
les responsabilités qu'on peut avoir par
rapport à l'environnement par rapport à
l'autre ensuite on se pose des questions
de forme d'un matériau le rapport à
l'espace de rapports aussi à l'habitant
au spectateur a empêché inventer de
nouveaux concepts c'est tout d'abord
s'interroger sur la ville et l'habitat
actuelle je suis et des capsules de café
pour représenter les habitats j'imagine
qu'on peut changer la forme de la maison
parce qu on a à peu près tous les mêmes
maisons déjà que cette future faut
battre les formes soit par est que
maintenant nous généralement cédé maison
carrée 1
et là il ya plusieurs formes il est
criant il ya des formes
rectangulaire ya toute forme en fait
tout est l'envié l'habitat et son
architecture influence directement de
paysages et bien souvent nous y
associons la notion de paysage urbain
pourtant elle est très vaste en fait de
son paysage et combien il est ici on
assume et sel commence placé dans le
futur une architecture une ville alors
que on est aujourd'hui dans les villes
penser comme des grandes métropoles
que deviendra la ruralité dansante en
200 ans et comment elle sera habitable
ça c'est un des points un des
traitements qu'on peut ce travail
donnera lieu en septembre 2015 à
l'exposition d'une sélection de ces
projets dans cette optique de
sensibilisation le frac développe
d'autres programmes poule architecture
l'art l'urbanisme questionne notre
conception du pays